So I mentioned this yesterday briefly, but
now I want to dig into it more that we're
starting to get actual results
from the Iowa caucus democratic candidate
mayor Pete boot edge edge is getting absolute
lutely crushed for having declared victory
in Iowa Monday night before any votes were
really counted.
You might remember that when there was about
one or 2% of the vote in on Monday before
all vote reporting stopped because of the
fiasco involving the app being used to communicate
results in Iowa, a boot edge edge was ahead
for about 30 minutes by a couple points.
Then it went to Bernie, but it was meaningless
because we had no results at the time.
And mayor Pete came out and gave a victory
speech and said, check out this video.
We don't know all the results, but we know
by the time it's all said and done, Iowa,
you have shocks the nation.
And then take a look at [inaudible].
This is a victory and there were not yet any
actual vote counts.
What a night
[inaudible]
because tonight an improbable hope became
an undeniable reality.
[inaudible]
it's actually making me cringe.
They're there.
We just didn't have account and he's basically
giving a victory speech.
Now Amy Klobuchar did a speech as well, but
she was just kind of positive.
She wasn't really implying or saying she won
or even doing anything close to claiming victory.
And then Buddha judge went on to say on Twitter,
quote, Iowa, you have shocked the nation by
all indications, we are going on to New Hampshire
at Victoria's hashtag Iowa caucuses.
Now based on the data we have as of this filming,
Pete boot edge edge does have a slight lead
over Bernie Sanders, but there are essentially
two possibilities for what took place here.
And we're going to discuss both of them.
He's getting crushed.
The hashtag mayor cheat was trending on Twitter.
He went on CBS yesterday morning trying to
explain himself.
Here's what he said,
the Sanders campaign also saying they're essentially
victorious there.
People online saying that your claim of using
the V word is, uh, I think the hashtag is
mayor cheat.
Uh, in retrospect you think it was a little
premature to take the stage and use the V
word?
No, I mean, looking at what happened last
night, looking at all of the data that we've
got, it was an extraordinary night and a,
we are absolutely Victoria's coming into New
Hampshire.
I mean this is a campaign that when we launched
a year ago, people said, you're, you're not
as Senator, you're not a national name
now, he still didn't have any results at the
time.
That interview was filmed and he's insisting
that he's victorious coming into New Hampshire.
So he was kind of doubling down and also backtracking,
kind of saying, well, listen, what I didn't
mean I literally won.
What I meant was that given the odds against
a mayor from a small town in Indiana as a
general thing, regardless of the vote totals,
I'm victorious merely because I got some delegates.
And so I see myself as Victoria's moving on
to New Hampshire.
So there's two possibilities here.
One is that this is like a super Griff Dery
consultant idea.
Some consultant came up with, Hey, let's just
go out and claim victory.
And then there will be headlines and you'll
do a speech and later we can reinterpret it.
As I just met that first small town mayor
to get delegates.
That's a win.
We don't even need to know the vote totals.
And in fact, mayor Pete was sort of a grifter
consultant to himself, so maybe it was actually
his own idea to do it.
The real problem here is that this doesn't
stop with mayor Pete in Iowa.
Once candidates get into this idea of just
claiming victory, even before there are votes,
no matter what, you are opening the door to
candidates, claiming they won the democratic
nomination, multiple candidates claiming that
they won, even if it hasn't actually been
decided.
You can get to November 3rd and Donald Trump
claiming he won even before we have the actual
numbers.
And then that becomes what Trump supporters
believe.
Even if later it turns out actually you didn't
win, someone else won.
Well, but Trump came out and said he claimed
victory.
It's a disastrous path to be going down and
this is 2020 American, uh, America.
That's the unfortunate reality.
And we have to be prepared for a version of
this in November, and even for the lead up
to the eventual Dominique, a nominee on the
democratic side, to have this type of victory
claim, absent actual evidence.
Now there's another side to this and we're
going to dig into this morning a little bit.
Um, there is the idea because a connection
has been found between a consultancy group
working on the Iowa caucus and mayor Pete.
There's the idea that the reason may or Pete
went out and claimed victory was because he
already knew that the vote counts would be
manipulated in his favor and he would ultimately
reign victorious.
Now I think it's important that, you know,
we find connections on Republican sides and
sometimes they're meaningful and sometimes
they're not.
And what you really have to understand is
that in the incestuous world of politics and
power in the United States, it's not surprising
to keep running into the same people frequently.
And we have to be more discerning than that,
right?
When Trump says he doesn't know love Parness
and Parness keeps showing up in videos talking
to Trump about Maria Ivana bitch and whatever
else.
At a certain point it starts to belie credulity.
When it comes to the mayor Pete thing, I don't
think that we should attribute to malice what
can be explained by incompetence, but I am
not saying there is definitively nothing to
see here when it comes to these consultant
groups and mayor Pete, let's talk about that
more in the next segment because it is, um,
it's important that we get this sort of under
control before people go too far with it.